good morning and evening distinguished
guest faculty members graduates
recording in
progress marks a momentous occasion As
We Gather here virtually to celebrate
the culmination of hard work dedication
and the Relentless pursuit of knowledge
this day is a testament to the
incredible achievements of each one of
you my name is moini singul and I'm
honored to be your host today as a
program manager at Sly learn I have had
the privilege of witnessing your journey
and I'm proud to be the part of this
Choice OAS alongside me is my co-host
Angelie myl who shares the same
commitment to your success
ESS before we move move for forward I
would like to express our gratitude to
Pia University for their collaboration
in making this convocation ceremony
possible their dedication to education
and Excellence has been undoubtedly
contributed to the success of our
graduates before we proceed forward I
would like to take a moment to reflect
on The Incredible Journey that has
brought us to this significant day
each one of you has transversed a path
that demanded dedication perance and a
substantial amount of time invested in
learning and growth I can imagine that
one of the most challenging aspects of
this journey was the commitment you
demonstrated by dedicating eight hours
every weekend week after week for 6 to
11 months the journey involved immersive
experience through live virtual classes
self-based online video
numerous assessments projects quizzes
and of course The Pinacle the completion
of your catom project completing
hundreds of hours of learning
successfully navigating through
assessments and taking on the
responsibilities of the real world
projects showcase not just your academic
power but also your commitment to
personal and professional
development today as you stand on the
brink of success it is only to applaud
and appreciate each and every one of you
for your unwavering efforts it takes an
extraordinary amount of commitment and
passion to achieve what you have
accomplished the sacrifices you made the
late night Spence stud and the
persistence you showed in overcoming
challenges have led you to this moment
of Celebration congratulations are truly
in order on this note I would like to
extend heartful gratitude to your
friends and family their continued
support understanding and encouragement
have played an instrumental role in
shaping your success story behind each
graduate there is a network of loved
ones who Shar this journey with them and
today it is much of a celebration of
their support as it of your
achievements today we had a privilege of
hosting a distinguished individual whose
contribution to academic and commitment
to Excellence have left an indial mark
on the field of electrical and computer
engineering I am delighted to introduce
Dr demitros the senior vice president
for p
University Dr peris embarked on his
academic Journey with a bachelor's
degree from the National Technical
University of Athens in
1998 his thir for knowledge led him to
the University of Michigan where he
earned both a master of s Engineering in
1999 and a doctorate in 2003 Dr peris
holds the extreme title of Riley
professor of electrical and computer
engineering showcasing his deep
expertise and scholarly contributions in
the field his current role as senior
vice president for pod University online
reflects his commitment to advancing
education through Innovation and
accessible meanss so we we are pleased
to have you in this ceremony today I
request you to share a few words with
all the
participants hello everyone thank you so
much for the kind introduction uh good
morning good evening and congratulations
I'm really really thrilled to be here
today with all of you and celebrate this
amazing
accomplishment uh it's an accomplishment
for all of the Learners uh that took a
lot of sacrifice and a lot of effort but
it's also a lot of accomplishment and a
big one for all of your loved ones your
families and friends and we're here to
celebrate all of you uh everybody who
contributed to this big success so
congratulations everyone we're so so
happy for
everybody I'd just like to sh a few
words um to also um let all of us know
how we got here uh and um it's really I
think interesting to note that when p
University moved to radically and
rapidly extend the online offerings that
we offer right now through our flagy
campus simply learn was one of our
earliest external partners and for a
good really good reason um we really
value this partnership and we look
forward to this continued growth because
both Purdue University and simply learn
understand the importance of online
learning we both really recognize that
success organizations today across the
entire world and across all Industries
depend on Highly Educated individuals
and skilled
Personnel we both recognize also that
this need is not static lifelong
learning upskilling and reskilling are
now integral features of our work lives
and frankly of our lives in
general constant learning and growing
are key for success
and I think we all recognize that and
particularly all of you that are now
successfully completing your
programs Purdue University and simply
learn get that and we understand the
integral role that all of us that online
learning can play in feeling this need
in all of our
lives and you know it's interesting
because unlike traditional learning
models online learning provides the much
needed flexibility that we all need in
our busy lives to
succeed and it's vital for working
professionals and I know many of you are
as you're trying to build up and enhance
your skills and as today's celebration
proves you have successfully done
that online learning is also a very
powerful tool for many individuals whose
early life educational opportunities may
have been quite limited due to economic
cultural and other barriers
to a large extent and I'm really happy
about this online education levels the
playing field by providing viable
additional opportunities for many of us
in life one example is that online
learning provides learning path for
Veterans as they transition from
military life to civilian
life and I know that the journey is not
ending here this is an important
Milestone but I know many of you are
going to be eager and hungry for
lifelong learning and I'm here to
encourage you to pursue additional
opportunities as you embark on the next
phase of your life and of course I hope
that you will think of Purdue as the
viable partner in this lifelong
journey online programs offered by
Purdue University include many other
options master's degrees Doctorate
Degrees in a variety of disciplines uh
micro courses professional certificates
digital budges executive webinars and
more for example among many other areas
we offer opportunities to gain critical
knowledge in uh emerging Fields like for
example Advanced manufacturing
artificial intelligence autonomy data
science Quantum Computing robotics
security and
semiconductors and flexibility is also
key here uh we enable students to
acquire skills
and and earn very fiber credentials in
their areas of Interest without
committing a priori toward completing a
full
degree many of our degrees are ranked
number one in the United States like for
example electrical engineering
industrial engineering mechanical
engineering Engineering Management and
many many
others so the bottom line for do
University and simply learn yet online
education
and we're deeply committed to that
having completed your simply learn
programs you clearly understand the
value of continuing your education on an
ongoing basis and the value that quality
online learning can bring to your
Endeavor once again congratulations to
you your families your friends your
loved ones and we hope that Purdue can
continue to serve your online
educational needs in the future
congratulations and boiler
up thank you Professor thank you so much
for sharing such inspiring words to all
the graduates present today thank you so
much thank you thank you very much
Professor now please join me in
welcoming Mr Kashi Dalal the co-founder
and Chief Operating Officer of Simply in
his role Mr kup oversees critical
function such as controllership tax
legal business finance and investor
relations with a career spanning over
two decades Mr kup has accumulated a
wealth of experience in the corporate
world his journey began with
multinational corporations including
unil Lev where he owned his skills in
sales and finance domains subsequently
he transitioned into the dynamic realm
of Indian consumer Tech businesses
making significant contribution to the
companies like ink fruit and zoi a true
business leader Mr Kasher is known for
his commitment in building reliable
endtoend processes with his strategic
Vision emphasis the creation of Robot
Framework that Empower Frontline team to
deliver exceptional customer success
consistently this approach reflects not
only in the success of Simply learn but
also in the broader impact on the
industry as a co-founder and COO of
Simply learn Mr Kash support for today's
event underscore simply learn commitment
to education Innovation and the success
of each graduate presenter his
dedication to fostering learning
environment aligns seamlessly with the
values we hold on this joyous
occasion without further Ado I would
like to invite kab to Enlighten our
audience with few words over to you Mr
kha thanks Angie uh hi everyone it's uh
I'm I'm really delighted to be here I
think these are the kind of events that
we all work hard for um you know super
excited to see hundreds of
professionals um you know working hard
on a program of this nature and and
being able to pursue their interests I
think that's that's the mission for
simply learn and everybody at simply
learn um and that's what keeps us going
so so a huge congratulations to all the
graduates of this program um and you
know so so one of the things that I you
know really Marvel at and and I really
want to talk about it is that lot of
times there is this perception that
doing an online program is easy um and I
can clearly see after years of
experience that it's not so there is a
huge hats off to all of you I think uh
Professor dimitrio touched on this that
this is a huge success for you your
loved ones um you have juggled the
demands of work family uh personal
aspirations and at the same time found
time to pursue this program uh this is a
long rigorous program it's not a short
course it's most of you would have spent
more than 150 hours worked on projects
taken time out you know spent time with
our learning teams to get uh your
Concepts cleared and and it's it's
definitely I'm sure it's it's led to a
lot of compromises and that's that's
what has got you here so so uh well done
huge congratul
I I think you should be proud of what
you've achieved and we definitely are so
so that's really something that you know
we should applaud and and really great
job to all the Learners and graduates um
we hope and I I sincerely hope that you
know this is going to be a turning point
for you uh when you graduate from a
program like this um I hope that this
will be the start of a New
Journey the world as we see it over the
last 10 years there's so much of change
right that there is uh you know in the
last 10 years there are new domains that
have opened up Fields like data science
Cloud security um and you know more
recently Ai and and you know with
generative ai ai is touching everyday
lives I think till even a year back
probably a lot of us thought about AI as
something that comes in Sci-Fi movies uh
but now if you look at it it it's so
personal that you can interact with AI
you can use AI in your everyday life and
and that's just U part of the cycle it's
not the end of the cycle there'll be new
technologies that will keep coming up um
and and that's really what we are super
excited about that how can we help you
through programs like these uh the kind
of programs that you've taken with
simply learn and Purdue um so that you
can look at this new world this
everchanging world and instead of
fearing change you can use it for uh
benefiting from it you can operate like
digital natives um operate in this world
where all these technology changes are
familiar you don't feel insecure around
them and use those opportunities to make
the most for yourselves I think that's
what keeps us going and and we sincerely
hope that this program will be a pivotal
point and and you can grab new
opportunities as you move ahead um so
once again a huge congratulations to all
the Learners and I would also like to
thank uh Professor dimitrios for his
time as well as P University without
whose support these programs would not
have been possible um so let me end with
that once again huge congratulations and
well
done thank you thank you so much Mr kha
for your kind
and knowledgeable words so beginning the
moment we have all been eagerly waiting
for has arrived it is the time to
celebrate the remarkable success of each
and every graduate present here my KH
moini and I are honored to collectively
felicitate and recognize the hard work
dedication and achievements of our
accomplished graduates we will Begin by
acknowledging the Achievers in each
category names will be called out by
program and we will have the privilege
of hearing from a few graduates about
their transformative experiences if by
any chance we mispronounce any name
please accept my sincere apologies your
achievements are of utmost important to
us and we want to ensure that each
graduate is recognized with the respect
they deserve in the spirit of
inclusivity if by any chance we missed
out call anyone's name we again
sincerely apologize for that your
achievement are no less significant and
we encourage you to reach out to us we
are committed to ensuring that every
graduate is acknowledged and we will
gladly accommodate you in the next
convocation ceremony without further Ado
let's begin with the first air of
graduates we will recognize the
Achievers of the postgraduate program in
digital marketing graduates as your name
are called please take a moment to bask
in the welld deserved recognition of
your accomplishments so moving to the
first air of category which is
postgraduate program in digital
marketing the graduates
are abishek Amit Anand Apna arushi D hwi
jant Karishma and Nikita congratulations
to all of you next up we have Rohit
sudipta Roy
and swaraj congratulations to all of
you next up we have arohi aay akansha
Akash akata akika Alita am Andrew ASF
benison Basi Bikram cam chaitanya
Daniela tan lakmi gorov ganali and G
congratulations to all of you next up we
have gisi Jes Jessica jar Zia siuan LNA
Madu Mandi Mani nandini Niha ninad parit
pitro rtia rocki Rohit Rika and sandhi
congratulations to all of you next up we
have santosi Satish Kumar shalu
sharmila sh Shas sidhar snika Shri sua
swand tasini wandana Yukiko Zahara Naga
Shivam brahmanand Ahmed and Kito
congratulations to all of you last but
not least we have sashank wein mohammadi
Mohammad Bilal Khan jant and nandani
congratulations to all of
you before we move on to the next
category we have Karishma in the
audience who would like to share our
experience with all of us can we please
move over to the
panelist kishma can you hear
us let's move on to the next category in
the me chish join and share their
experience with us
sure the next category belongs to
postgraduate program in data engineering
and Achievers
are G satarupa vas and congratulations
to all of you Amy Ashish vikas Darren
tanun Gish Jesse Joe Marino Milad King
Nothing bong pun
Rahul s Shila Sola shash Rahul and
Anusha congratulations to all the
Achievers for the next set of category
which is postgraduate program in data
science the graduates
are anjil anit Arab ashini ainash D Dr
vayat FIA Ganesh and goam
congratulations to all of you next up we
have Harrison Ibrahim Jaa lakmi Shri
Kant crany Kumar Krishnan Mahesh mahid
Manan and manov congratulations to all
of you next up we have Manu Mohammad
Monica naven nupa Ray RMA sankes sanan
and Shan congratulations to all of you
next we have thip Venita and malti
congratulations to all of you next we
have adiya adiya kataria Amit bti amok
anuda Aura bash Katrina Chung Wang
kilichi rajes Deepak danash deepti Fong
Gish gopal har Krishna Hari Prasad and
him congratulations to all of you next
we have Zanna Jonathan Kin Kaz loes Zina
nir maluk manjun manra Maru Mo nagashri
Nancy Narendra Nasi obina Phillip Sanjay
and sagana congratulations to all of
you next up we have sandip Sanjay
savitri Shan sashikant Shilpa Shivani
shubam SN snan sham sushil tesini Toni
Varun vasundra vges Vijay Wilson and
Yash
congratulations to all of
you last but not least we have yogendra
yoges VI karik and prakash basudev
congratulations to all the
graduates before we move on to our next
category we have malti in our audience
who would like to share her experience
with all of us can we please move malti
to the
panelist hi can you hear me yes m we
can hello everyone uh first of all
congratulations to all the people who
have completed their respective
courses um and I'd like to um highlight
my experience with simply learn I'm
basically a career trying to change my
career right now and as Mr Dalal had
mentioned nowadays everyone is talking
about data science Ai and analytics so I
have done my engineering but it was
almost 20 years to the date so so I
wanted to change my career and I also
wanted to upskill myself and that's why
I've chosen this program and uh I found
it to be a very good experience uh they
they were very flexible especially all
the instructors the uh learning support
managers and everyone they they always
answered the queries on time they were
very quick in responding to whatever
needs I had and overall I found it to be
very good and the content especially I
think it was very useful and um thank
you very much and uh once again
congratulations to everybody who's
completed their courses and looking
forward to a better career from now on
thanks that's great thank you maldi
thank you so much for sharing your
experience with
us so on we do have few testimonials
from few of our Learners uh so we have a
testim from David who has shared his
experience with all of his for his
program thank you David for sharing your
experience we do have testimonial from
mahid also who has equally shared his
experience regarding the program with us
thank you so much Ma for sharing this
experience with
us there is one more testimonials which
we have received from crany from the
same program thank you so much crany for
sharing this experience with
us the next category belongs to post
project program in data analytics and
the graduates
are Atul Krishnan esini Belin B blessing
deepti Dakar Divya ashwari and Anusha
congratulations to all of you next up we
have franka Janine ch laki Len MGA
Nikita pranita Raji ranji and SAA
congratulations to all of you shafa shuu
Tam T and Yesa congratulations to all of
you Aisha Adis Alexandra Amit Andrew Ari
Kellen jadan chti Davi D Dana
Denise banjan Donald fak glendis Hira
rushi and Isha congratulations to all of
you ja John Jordan liita Lyin Manish
Maran M Mohamad Muhammad faran moit
mundu M Nini nain Niha nimi nsh Olga and
Omnia congratulations to all the divers
pranal pratik riti Roni sain Sahar
sanjie Satish Shilpa Shilpa Kari Shakara
sonali Shivan S T Thomas Vish Vish shind
yamini Y and congratulations to all of
you V Dan
Sund Dias suu Anna and Christopher
congratulations to all of
you before we move on we have a few
testimonials from the graduates we would
like to express our gratitudes towards
your inspiring testimonial thank you so
much for sharing next up we have ishwari
who had share her experience with us
thank you for taking our time to share
your experience with all of us today
thank you so very
much for postgraduate program in digital
Supply Chain management the graduates
are Arun Brahma priel vun yagna Ganesh
jri yuhi Mohammad fan Mohammad Abdul and
Tash congratulations everyone next we
have Tushar and Usman congratulations to
all of
you
next up we have abilash Akay aay rogi
anik anit Arjun ashini asmita ainash bat
Kumar deanin Jes kumra Guru kumran
mahalakshmi Mohammad Bashir pankaj padel
prabakar raghunandan and ranji
congratulations to all of you
next we have SAA sandip sudipto sua Tri
VI Yanka and de congratulations to all
of
you before we move on to our next
category we have tesi who have shared
her testimonials and showcased her
experience with us thank you so much
thri for sharing your
experience next category belongs to post
project program in digital PR
transformation and the graduates are
aish abijit Amit anupam AAA Arun thh
honey Joel and Mar congratulations to
all of you Mand mul Michael vesan Nim
Samir bov shiv prakash Shar suban
congratulations to all of you T and the
congratulations to both of
you aay anupa arav am
bani Faruk guhan hammed jender J
jitendra K Muhammad Lakshmi Pavan paully
sanil Sanjay Sara sharti andani
congratulations to all of you sudhakar
Alo Vishnu
me suban and Shaman congratulations to
all of
you before On To The Next program I
would like to call Arun from the
panelist to share his experience with
all of
us we can move on to the
next next up I would like to invite B to
share a few words with all the graduates
today
looks like technical glit viber v the
Viber can you hear
us no issues we move
forward foros graduate program in a and
machine learning the graduates
are pavna Chu darl dhes the Ganesh
Harish Ayan Judit and Saturday
congratulations everyone next up we have
shedi shria vid V and juli
congratulations to all of
you next up we have color Alexis
am Ana Andres ARA Asha abesh bab bihari
benzamin bit Santos chos claudo Deepak
gurprit Jacob Joshua Kiran hiral and
mariu congratulations to all of
you next up we have Rahul Matthew n an
abido Prav Ruck Rajiv rajes Rashmi Reena
Reza Sai Kiran saaru s Shanti sharat
Shilpa shuti stepen and sugna
congratulations
everyone next up we have suan Sur suam
tatarin and Johns congratulations to all
of
you before we move on we have Sheri who
would like to share his experience with
all of us can we please move him to the
panelist Shad can you hear us hi good
afternoon good morning and good evening
all of you and congratulations for the
achievement uh thank you very much for
giving me the opportunity um I'm a
graduate of
95 electronics and telecommunication
engineering so quite quite a Time far
since I left college and like five years
back I thought of like experimenting the
online concept so I've done courses from
MIT Cornell and London School of
economics and I think it's an
interesting experience to Bringing
education at at such a feasible way of
delivery for people who may not be able
to come back to college and study and
it's a quite experience I think there's
a interesting work done by simply learn
learn and the collaboration with
universities to Bringing such education
to uh to people
online been an interesting experience
thank you for
that thank you so very much sh for
sharing your wonderful experience with
us it was it was very nice hearing from
you thank
you we do have testimonials from few off
leer so Harish has shared his
testimonial for the program thank you so
much Harish for sharing your experience
with
us the next category belongs to
postgraduate program in business
analysis and the graduates are Akash aay
Ajit Akash Akshay ashini
vaaran B and chaman congratulations to
all of you Dr Niha Ezekiel rajash shakar
Gabriela
shasa geni Gotham Isha ji and Marshall
congratulations to all of you MRI
Melissa peace nashri Nicholas nikel Ali
K Prine and Raji congratulations to all
of you Sadam shba SI Prasad sham Sha s
Raj sham Panda sufia swapna Rani and STI
congratulations to all of
you Taran Jessie twinkle UD laki Vara
Wasim Vata VMA vinodini and Hava
congratulations to all of you aushi
Abdul aiz abinas Abu aders Aditi AA Akil
Ali Alisia Amit Amit an anur anur Singh
Anna Maria ano Arpita Ashish and ashini
congratulations to all of you next up we
have aita asani aushi Babu Bianca Braha
paru Brian chura darl djit Deepa D
danush DEA ETA Enoch Eva gagna gorov and
her congratulations to all of you next
up we have harida hasida hna hu himani
ishan Ishani
jagaran Jake Jes Jessie Kalani kameswari
Kik Kina gay
KH Ki harika and arunachal
congratulations to all of you next up we
have lakmi laana Meo Martin Magna
Muhammad Muhammad Alti moit
moit n miti Nas nain Naina Nita cuti Uka
bavi pruna
Patrick and pabin congratulations to all
of you Puja
paja Mohan pran prti pram PR prian
Ragini Rahul ramnas ranoy R Rika ruchira
sadya s San sharat Shada congratulations
to all of
you sh Shi shakar Shivam shha suit shiny
sides SI Simi simran SN sujan Steve Su
suiran t tirupati b venkatesu Andel
congratulations to all of you V vaj and
Val a huge congratulations to all the
graduates now now before we move on I
would like to call Ezekiel from the pan
from the participants to share a few
words with the graduates can we please
move him to the
panelist yeah um can you hear me thank
you everyone um it's my pleasure to uh
congratulate all the other uh Co
graduants today especially on business
analyst uh I wanted to express my
sincere gratitude so simply learn and
puzzle University USA uh it's has been a
great uh learning uh experience uh
throughout the business
analysis uh your expertise in such uh is
a wonderful and uh I appreciate uh that
we your patient and uh you're I mean
taking us through uh this uh wonderful
uh business analyst has been a very
inspirational to me and all other
students uh I would say this is not the
beginning but it's just a starting point
uh we appreciate everything that your to
us and other uh Learners have you know
Coop us to make sure that we get the
best out of it uh I appreciate the time
and effort invested in helping
developing a statical skill and
strategic thinking your feedback
encouragement have are invaluable and I
feel very equipped to say yeah uh this
is just a journey that just started I
hope that um we all get to a very good
and successful in all our endeavors
thank you so much congratulations
everyone
bye thank you thank you for
sharing you know your testimonial with
us today it was great your journey about
uh simply learn about your program all
together so a huge congratulations to
you from Simply end on successfully
completing your program a big
congratulations next up uh I would like
to share a few other testimonals from
fellow graduates this one is from
Melissa Gracia who completed the
postgraduate program and business
analysis and next we have from ship
Prasad V so again thank you so much for
taking our time and sharing your
testimonial with all of us today it is
in good spirit it goes along with it so
thank you so much next I would like to
call
beov um who is a graduate from digital
transformation I would request you to
share a few words with all of us
regarding your journey de yeah uh thank
you uh for giving me this opportunity to
speak uh I would like to express my
profound gratitude uh to Simply learn
and perdu
University uh to assist me uh completing
this uh postgraduation program in
digital
transformation I sorry uh just my uh my
kid is with me so uh sorry for the
interruption so
uh this program has simply helped me uh
to gain much more uh de insights with
the current working that I have in the
organization and has helped me to grow
prosper in my uh organization and uh
this would be uh the parallel example
would be uh the colleagues from my
organization are also interested in
rolling out uh to this uh program
because they have seen uh what amount of
projects have done uh to utilize the
knowledge which I have gained so that's
really helpful uh in many ways and uh
really sincerely thanks to you uh for
giving me this opportunity again to talk
and congratulations to all my fellow uh
uh graduates uh that's uh from all the
various courses thank
you thank you so much Fe thank you so
much for sharing your experience with
all of us today and it's great to know
that what you have learned is really
helping you in your professional career
as well so a great kudos to you
congratulations once again thank you
thank
you now moving on ladies and gentlemen
as we continue our celebrations It's
Time To Shine the spotlight on some
exceptional achievements we understand
that every one of you have demonstrated
dedication and hard work throughout this
journey and today we have the pleasure
of recognizing outstanding
accomplishment with the scholar award
The Scholar award honors the top two
performers in each category these
remarkable individuals have not only
attended live classes but have excelled
in projects and assessments showcasing
the highest cumulative scores their
commitment to Excellence and pursuit of
knowledge sets them
apart moving on to the first category
which is post data postgraduate program
in digital transformation we have ship
prakash who scored
87.8% and a will who scored
87.2% the next category belongs to
digital Supply Chain management the
winners are yagna who completed with
84.38% and suto with 83.78%
congratulations to all the
winners the next category belongs to
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning the winners are Saturday who
completed the program with
84.9% and those who completed the
program with 84.3
38% the next category belongs to data
engineering the winners are Anusha who
completed the program with
83.9% and Amy who completed the program
with 82.2 1% congratulations to all the
winners next category belongs to
postgraduate program in business
analysis the winners are theim who
completed the program with 82.5 7% and
AA who completed the program with 82.4
9% next category belongs to postgraduate
program in digital marketing the winners
are Chetan who completed the program
with
87% and Zahara who completed the program
with 83% congratulations to all the
winners next up we have postgraduate
program in data science the winners are
Mohammad who completed the program with
90% And vasundra who completed the
program with
84.8% Plus last but not the least we
have postgraduate program in data
analytics vazar mcul who completed the
program with 84.1 5% and Andrew who
completed the program with
83.4% congratulations to all the winners
congratulations the next category of
awards is the speedrunner award the
speedrunner award celebrates the
Learners who with unwavering dedication
and Focus accelerated through the
program completed it in record time
their efficiency and determination to AB
absorb knowledge at an accelerated Pace
set them apart in this unique
category for the first set of program
which is postgraduate program in digital
transformation we have Michael who have
completed the program in 89 days and aay
in 94 days
moving on for postgraduate program in
digital Supply Chain management Ganesh
has completed the program in 92 days and
the bingen in 99 days congratulations to
all of you moving on for postgraduate
program in a and machine learning chus
has completed in 108 days and Shanti in
days for postgraduate program in data
engineering we have Miller who have
completed the program in 12 121 days and
Anusha in 141 days congratulations to
all of
you moving on for postgraduate program
in business analysis we have Rika who
completed the program in 95 days and
shiny in 97
days for postgraduate program in digital
marketing Amit has completed in 99 days
and Yuko in 108 days congratulations to
all of
you moving on to our next Next
program for postgraduate program in data
science we have himl who have completed
in 95 days and Von who have completed
the program in 101
days moving on for postgraduate
programming data analytics Vishal has
completed the program in 99 days and
midu in 141 days congratulations to all
the
GS now I would like to introduce you to
the team behind the scenes the team that
has worked relentlessly to make sure you
have the best learning experience now
this is for you to put a face to the
names you may have heard and interacted
within the past
year so moving
on I would first like to call out our
life class instructors they have been
the major pillars of your experience and
I would like to thank each one of them
on your behalf
so thank you very much to amendra Billy
Mohammed vajah F gep Kil Prashant Sayan
Prashant ner and sahil thank you very
much I would also like to thank our life
class instructors prep berad Mark minel
cm anjuna and nagendra thank you so very
much so before we move move on I would
really like to call out Professor
Armando who would like to share his
experience and knowledge with us can we
please move him to the
panelist sure absolutely can you hear me
loud and clear yes absolutely sir
fantastic so first first thing I would
like to congratulate everyone for
embarking this journey for taking the
leap that not everyone takes in trying
to pursue something beyond your skills
and get outside your comfort zone it's
not only the the people around you that
have faith in you whether what's your
family what's your managers
collaborators friends us but it's you
who actually deci to have a little bit
more Fai of you and invest time and
invest effort in learning something that
is critical for the world that we live
in today where um where there's this
everchanging fast pace right and as you
Embark this journey beyond all the
knowledges whether it's data engineering
data analytics transformation digital
marketing business analysis AI supply
chain the science you are actually
stepping into a world that brings a lot
of opportunities but also a lot of
challenges right so the skills that you
have been harvesting today and the and
the knowledge they have acquired will
position you in a very unique situation
to influence to innovate and transform
everything that you touch because right
now we live in this ever ever constantly
evolving landscape right so your impact
will extend far beyond a code and
algorithms right you're actually
stepping into a world where decision
with every single decision that you make
and the technologies that now you're
capable to develop will have a very
profound implication on society so now
more than ever the world needs you right
the world needs leaders and needs people
who are not only skilled but have also
been acquired this sense of impact right
this kind of a Nord and ethical Compass
so as you continue navigating through
these opportunities that have opened to
you um just always make sure that you
keep the implications and what you do in
mind and heart right let let you be uh
transparent uh and let's Ure sure that
you really start conversations on the
implications of things that we as
Humanity are starting to understand we
are living in an era where change has
never been as fast and it's not going to
stop it's going to continue move forward
so the same way as you took the leap to
learn your skills don't don't lose that
and continue living that continue being
lifelong lers you will now be stewards
of De integrity and deal trust right in
this era where data can be a force for
both own parallel good and unended
consequences your commitment to ensure
that you understand the implication what
you do is
pount so first I would like you to
congratulate every one of you reaching
this Milestone the future is not just
something that you enter the future is
something that now you will be creating
so I'm very excited to see the world
that you will build uh now with your
skills and knowledge where technology
serves not just a tool for Progress
right but but but but a Beacon of Hope
and a beacon of progress for all of us
so uh I really want to thank all of you
for the commitment I want to thank all
of you for the active
discussions and for also to giving us a
trust to help you shape your minds
toward the individuals you want to
become so without anything else and
thank you very much
congratulations and uh enjoy uh Rejoice
on the new learning of the new knowledge
you have and apply them and apply all
this knowledge in the sense of progress
and um and collaboration so this
experience with you has been amazing the
discussions the the even the coding
techniques um the engagement from all of
you the support from the STA simply earn
and produce so again you had a whole
team that has been working very hard so
that you can jump into the world and
make an impact so thank you very much
everyone again
congratulations for your new
achievement thank you so very much for
your wishes and sharing your knowledge
thank you very
much so moving
on I would also like to invite nagendra
from digital transformation program and
he would also like to share his
knowledge with all of us can we please
move hi everyone hope I'm audible
Angelie yes absolutely sir okay
fantastic I've been to this a few times
with you folks and thank you for
inviting me and it's always very
thrilling for me to be here because I
see many familiar names uh especially
part of the awards list people who are
coming to that very interesting and very
important Milestone as an outcome of
your long journey with us so first my
heartfelt congratulations to all of you
I think it's um as arando was saying
before it's a time to rejoice in terms
of this very long but very interesting
Journey that you have taken with us and
I hope um like you know you'll convey
this to your family members as well for
all the sacrifices they have made some
of you have joined at 6:00 a.m. your
time others have joined continue to be
with me 11:30 p.m. your time and it's
always been great to see that enthusiasm
and energy continue despite the OD or
some of you joined at so um I'll I'll
keep this short um one I wanted to
convey that it's a a very connected
world out there and I hope you'll U get
plenty of opportunities to apply the
learnings from what we talked about in
class and make the world a better place
I hope you get a chance to do what
you're going to enjoy um and I also want
to call out that all these classes all
these hours that we spent together was
equally enjoyable for me because the
kind of discussions we had the kind of
uh exercises we went through the
activities we did in class uh and the
kind of examples you folks brought out
with your Rich experiences was simply
amazing I think it made a very holistic
learning experience uh the last thing
I'd like to call out as I always did in
class is remember as you go out there
and look to solve complex problems um
empathy can be your best friend uh that
deep sense of empathy for your
stakeholders across the world in terms
of what they're looking for to get from
you what value you can deliver to them
let that be our guiding force so with
that uh thank you very much for having
me here and all the very best to you and
again once again heartfelt
congratulations thank you so very much
sir for taking out the time and coming
yet is always it's always nice hearing
you thank you so very much my
pleasure so now moving on I would also
like to thank our Master Class
instructors for facilitating classes on
several interesting topics every month
so thank you very much to professor
wenka and Sarah thank you very
much moving on I would also like to
thank Dr B Dr Z Professor Eric Professor
Michelle and Professor jinu thank you
very
much
so let's now move on to the simply learn
team that provided endless support
throughout your journey these individual
were responsible for moderating all
sessions and the support tickets you
submitted many of you may have
interacted with them directly or
indirectly so thank you to ashini Asha
Harish Malik Arjun rakshit rames Yim and
Puja thank you very much I would also
like to thank ziran Anish mini prma
Irene vikas Rohan SEL surj Shani sa
prasada and maku thanks to all of
you now moving on now let's thanks our
product team this team is the brain
behind curating the program and
structuring it so huge thanks to gorav
Agarwal abinav aul moan shivika and Sh
thank you very much
team now to the team responsible for all
the content and curriculum that we see
in terms of live virtual classes labs
and self-learning videos so huge thanks
to Baki Dr anjana arushi and Kunal thank
you very
much the next team I would like to thank
is the faculty and the alignment team
who are responsible to give us one of
the best trainers
so thank you to Vijay Jonathan kasim
Punam fedos Ashish and Anisha thank you
very
much and last but not least let's thank
our leadership team who regulates the
direction of all program and oversees
the learner success team a big thanks to
Rahul sh sidhar SAS HIIT my co-host
moini subashini and Kya thank you very
much thank you to all of
you before we bring this memorable
convocation ceremony to a close I want
to express a heartfelt gratitude to each
and every one of you who actively engage
with us on various social media
platforms your reviews feedbacks and
expression of appreciation have been the
source of immense joy and motivation for
all of us as you B fairwell to this
convocation ceremony we invite you to
stay connected with us follow our social
media handles for updates news and
ongoing learning opportunities your
journey doesn't end here and we are
excited to continue
supporting to your path of success in
conclusion a heartfelt thanks to each
and every graduate their family members
faculty and everyone who contributed to
the success of this event your presence
in participation have made this
convocation ceremony truly special we
extend our warmest wishes for your
future endeavors remember being
aspirational is the first step toward
success and today you stand equipped
with knowledge and experience to pursue
your dreams
confidently thank you for your time your
trust and your commitment this event
would not have been successful without
each and every one of you as we bit you
good night good day and good luck
may your journey ahead be filled with
success growth and fulfillment
congratulations and until we meet again
stay inspired and keep reaching for the
Stars
goodbye thank you everyone and
goodbye